ja alle gleich schlecht
leute was geht hier vor maxime wir
spielen heute wie er das sind wenige und
ich einfach es ist ein kleines turnier
darauf hatte ich lust und danach wenn
wir gegeneinander kämpfen und wir sind
beide ziemlich raus aus pvp ja wenn ich
im vergleich zu wenig überhaupt schon
jemals drin war
jetzt sagt noch scheinen mehr mut ist
mein zweiter vorname sollte aber ich
glaube auch immer mit reis gegeben
der andere kommt vorsichtiger
der pinguin hat den 1
klar vor den anderen weg
sabine weggeputzt gott halte ich bei der
wm nichts dran
aber irgendwie man verlernt
ich bin lohner du bist auch okay
bei mir geht es aber ein kind kommt als
ich außerdem
ich hoffe die nazis vor das wollte ich
nicht knopf richtigen trends bei mir
machst dich okay da geht direkt kampflos
erst direkt einen apfel ist ja allein
schon sagen wir hätten uns ein
kämpfertyp bis hier vorne erringt
einfach weg alles ist anders
er macht in den richtigen rat am start
er versteht die referenz
wo läufst du hin
ich glaube das ist weniger irgendwie
taktisches rennen als einfach dumm sein
durch kleiner stellen direkt nächste
runde alter letzte runde ich mal was bei
der zone also für die all stars treffen
würden lasst den schmuck ist in dem park
ist egal es bei geschlossen
nein hab ich halt da braucht man konnte
noch nicht treffen
sehr schön die maschinen durch das los
aber sehr gut obwohl wir echt lange kein
pvp spieler aber das verlernt man echt
nicht glaube so diese aller letzten
feinschliff so dass du so richtig gut
bist dafür braucht ewigkeiten aber so
dass man so sieht man die ganze zeit man
kommt nicht mehr raus wenn man seine
zeit wider genau aber so eine stabile
basis dass man selbst combos verteilen
kann und so das verlernt man steht immer
noch erst mit ihren geschichten andere
leute ist auch schränken weil jeder
denkt sieht dr
und keiner assoziiert das team und mich
damit wahrscheinlich ist er in ordnung
hier oder löschen
schnell abgezogen
den kriegen aber auch auf jeden fall
jeden fall noch ein treffer ich hatte
keine feinde mehr
leider keinen treffer
was sie was die srg com oder älter wäre
irgendwie sind wir immer die die am
längsten kämpfe erst mal gold ab
außerdem hat kenne ich gar nicht kenne
es ist nicht neu ich glaub einiger
maßnahme jetzt schon verworfen
und bist der du weiter ich hab dich
geboxt wird ja yamaha skeptiker
verbleibende teams zwei okay acht wir
waren im finale gerade das war mir noch
einen mini turnier machen
nach sony zwar schon alles was ich
wollte
dann startet alter so viel zu mini
turniers haben sie eigentlich alle mal
gecheckt gehabt dass wir es machen wie
viel zum minister gesagt erst wenn der
manchmal zwei gold- äpfel auf einmal ist
ja du bist du aus dem star trek team mit
der hand damit das nicht passiert dass
wir auch nur bei gott öffnen sich
gefühlt robin wright homburg aber ich
bin grad abstrakt mit meinem holen du
dir bin gerade abgehauen
das gleiche ein herz oder ein halbes
oder so ich mein gesicht nicht
unterrichten was ist denn los dass das
mir diese töten aber jetzt irgendwie so
hat eben ging das wie schnell haben wir
immer länger gekämpft jetzt müssen wir
warten war ein kampf der kampf hier
beweist du das noch
verbleibender stern direkt am anfang
ja ich denke mal dass ich gucke auch
hier in essen was zum weiß weiß genannt
ok das ist mein kate immer diese leute
diesen wilders
wir setzen auf die seite von kirk alter
denn alter berichtet walter leykauf du
müssen allerdings noch mitgehalten alter
hast bei denen es zu geleckt
viacom alter was soll ich da machen
bist du gestorben wo ich konnte absolut
nichts machen was habt ihr bestimmt
gesehen aber egal dann zwölf
wahrscheinlich sowieso ein bisschen
langen geben nochmal / lobby und auf
server 800 machen wir auch ein kleines
best of three ok ok wenig kraft so
vielleicht längsten kann ich glaube
nicht
frau war haben wir auch schon mal
gekämpft sondern ganz trennen hat mir
jetzt in der lobby getroffen da war es
gar nicht mal so schlecht für dich oh ja
genau ich habe auch den den zwei gold
will auf einmal back gehabt ungefähr
aber du hast mir so erklärt gab jemanden
behilft und daher kann ich mir selbst
vorwürfe machen
intense intends to the track wenig
hattest du nochmal pushen
ich hatte sogar noch eine gehabt ich
hätte so gerne gehabt so richtig scheint
nicht so schnell zu wechseln
tipp die karten zwei genannter kombi
topdeq jedoch weg zum glück bin ich
vollkommen korrekt wegen sind gerade
darin report kleinert ich bin vollkommen
korrekt freunde der als einer besten
noch mal kommen wird des lebens rein
gedrückt
das war für ihn geht schon an die ich
hier nochmal der letzte kampf die letzte
möglichkeit irgendwie meine ehre
wiederherzustellen
wo war das noch mal mit meiner ehre
wiederherstellen ehre wiederherstellen
es eigentlich lenker begriff aber ich
kann das system sieht aber für diese
mahnung plätzen
ja du hast dir den gold apfel zur
richtigen zeit mit eingezogen zeitig auf
machen sollen naja ok von ich hoffe es
hat euch gefallen
wir bieten jetzt gespielt die
doppelrunde am anfang relativ cool muss
ich sein
da hätten wir um ein haar gewonnen aber
jetzt gerade eben hat ihn ein bisschen
musik wobei teilweise was auch ich muss
meine taktik überdenken
schau mal war wenig vorbei da haben wir
letzte woche glaube ich oder vor ein
paar tagen rocket league gezeigt und die
oder bin ich sagen macht's gut bis dahin
und bis zum nächsten mal tschüss